[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] miss Lee we've got building
conspiracy tornado trouble and a storm
dong
take it away two-face long dong dong
dong dong dong time doot doot doot doot
donk donk donk donk donk long time time
don't strong
[Music]
all right so Tom Hanks's tweets went
viral
tell Isis I love Tom Hanks's so it says
you mean is hilarious building I've ever
seen what the [ __ ] goes on inside thanks
Hank
I love Hank he was referring to this
building here that does look scary that
looks like some 1984 [ __ ] where the [ __ ]
you enter like some dungeon [ __ ] heaven
it's like with the Game of Thrones where
the god of many faces live oh yeah Jenna
prison it looks like a jail it looks
like death machine what is that Oh more
people had their own ideas of what this
building might be would you like to read
that is where nightmares are made the
National cookies center cookie be I'm
pretty sure Daenerys Daenerys Targaryen
keeps her dragons there now the tower of
missing socks once they leave their I
already this has to be a Scientology
temple where they perform audits with a
meters and draw up battle plans to fight
aliens led by Xena
sooo long bro hmm yeah so those are some
responses to this viral tweet and you
guys came up with your own
but someone ended up responding to that
tweet saying calm down it's an apt
building originally used to route our
transatlantic comm lines entirely full
of telecom equipment only 1/2 dozen
texts and engineers work they're doing
boring things like maintaining video
feeds for broadcasters filming live
events like the storage it's just a
bunch of servers fact all the way up
only 12 people you don't need no windows
or anything like that
yeah Thames RC I like tanks though
design plan off King in a stone building
tell me it's a stone building I'm not
sure what it's made out of but I know
that it's
lower Manhattan and it was completed in
1974 other we look so disgusted
it just looks dangerous but if it's made
out of so it looks pretty solid I don't
know it's just certain buildings give me
bad vibes and that one it's like the
ugly guy in the group oh yeah I mean
it's a beautiful building it just looks
a little freaky biggie I thought it was
a prison okay nothing positive Kate you
you know what they need to do they need
to hire one of those advertising
advertisement mirrorless people's to
come up and paint up to looking like
something on the side SpongeBob
SquarePants make it fun you know like do
something different considering how
grumpy I am now at my young age when I
get older I'm probably going to build a
house like that that just screams get
the [ __ ] away from me where were your
kids I don't know Lorna you want a house
with no windows I don't know I got to
think about that part of this realtor
not talk faster than she thought yeah I
think the goal is to keep people away
from me yeah but now you have Windows
now if you have an open yeah my whole
time you see what if it's eight stories
tall it'd still be darkest but be seven
stories any dark you don't know we have
a vision you guys don't get it it's not
your fault no not you know I mean to me
when I'm never mean I like you that one
over there not so much I don't care yeah
I do favorite little bit man this is all
terrible this continued with him there's
no such dinners mean I had a house
without windows and it [ __ ] suck
remember that place in Cape Town that
ever been the model part I mean I'm
pressing darkest one look when we danced
the back screams good ah oh yeah I mean
it was it was a nice place like it just
had like the rooms were built but
everything but it was so dark I would
wake up in depression every day every
five it's like whatever you wake up it
doesn't matter it's dark in there so
it's a good movie how can you tell can't
tell it all that's true the house that
we lived in previous because it was a
duplex so half of the whole house didn't
have any way
there's only the other half and then
that half of the house never really got
the Sun so the same thing about this
house that I have right now too much
[ __ ] sunlight everywhere
I can't like oh my god I can't sleep but
it's great I rather have more sunlight
than not it makes you feel like a home
me too oh my god dude wait what the [ __ ]
- look on our end he's running away with
this banana phone medical it feels
pretty comfortable it's nice and cold
you should travel with that I know huh
I should call it like an egg chill on
the plane hahaha do they have something
where you could like I want to get the
thing where you inflate in a plane and
then you lean on it to sleep on it I
[ __ ] you've been talking about this for
the past five years he eventually got a
[ __ ] beach ball and then he related
it on the plane and then they think they
told you sure you can't like that wasn't
me yes you pull remember that that's
right I like you like that's what that's
why I don't do with that [ __ ] running
good I feel like Siri you can't have
that on the plane oh you know what it is
because you're supposed to have things
under your seat or whatever you know
supposed to have anything there but it's
[ __ ] I forgot about that
Brian next story there is this tweet
that went viral as well and it looks
like this was it Hank no I don't care so
it's caption where there's a guy and one
along my beast mowing the lawn with the
breathing is there I still miss it place
in Canada they got tornadoes in Canada
mm-hmm Oklahoma thing yeah but not
Alberta damn tornadoes all up in the
middle of the [ __ ] so casual
about that [ __ ] you got [ __ ] to do okay
like moves on because of the tornado
doesn't mean you stop not even dressed
for the tornado either and just for the
summer
you don't get no [ __ ] you wearing shorts
and a t-shirt that is not tornado
clothes I'm almost 100% sure he's blind
the a blind guy morning lon you must be
[ __ ] up
baby I've done good job honey no point
did not Photoshop at all this is real
life and so apparently what the wife is
saying is that she wants to go to a good
nap and when she woke up she noticed
that there was a tornado happening and
that her husband was moving a lot but
it's not telling him she took the
picture I would do the same thing babe
look at that [ __ ] picture not so
apparently like their kid ran inside and
I told her like hey dad's won't come and
there's a tornado so then she goes
outside she's like what but they're
saying that in the photo it looks really
close but in real life it was really far
away and the tornado is actually moving
away from them oh yeah and that there
weren't a lot of people in their
backyard taking photos but this guy he
was just like well I'm keeping my eye on
it is what he was saying about the
tornado which one was yes that sure
looks like it's coming to him yeah
that's a beautiful photo though it is
beautiful disasters I look at that like
beauty is scarce it's not gonna be I
mean it scares me but mother nature's
beautiful that's the only part of mother
nature do
no I just think on it oh wait where
somebody fell in it's beautiful when no
one gets hurt exactly thank you Joe like
a volcano Wow look at the volcanoes
beautiful isn't it and then I mean
someone's burning now that's not that's
not beautiful anymore Nature can turn on
you all mother earth is a [ __ ] yeah so
here a couple of reactions to or like
you know there made it into a mean
they're like did you do your chores yet
no I'll cut off your phone - there's
burn industry next one accurate
representation of what adulthood looks
like well you don't give a [ __ ] about
you there's always [ __ ] happening briefs
gonna move on oh I don't do that if
there's a tornado I'm like [ __ ] it man
we've can grow I don't care for the
[ __ ] tornado how often do they get
tornadoes they must get it a lot where
they don't care just for us is it
sprinkles people freak the [ __ ] out and
they have umbrellas and raincoats and
ugg boots come out and it's just like
little sprinkles my favorite outfit in
California there's the short shorts with
the sweater and the ugg boots and the
scars don't forget the old art I don't
know why you need a [ __ ] scarf in LA
but all right there I own so many that I
can never work
well you you're cold all the time for no
goddamn reason is Jericho cold a 60
degrees so then I always forget about my
skirt and I'm out in the cold on my
hanger I think it's because like scarves
look look they look cute for a girl you
know but so you guys sacrifice the
discomfort for the cuteness I hate the
cars makes me smell no I'm sure it's not
this car that makes you not because it
makes me all sweaty and [ __ ] so I'm like
sweating the [ __ ] out of the scarf and
then I take it off it smells all musky I
said we don't need a scarf here man
like it's way too hot I thought I never
had a scarf my whole life just hey it's
like a menelaus connors but it was cold
there this one no don't get it twisted
it's not the scarf that makes for a last
story we have the Tai Chi master guys
ass kicked again yeah what's up with all
these Chinese cultural matters get their
ashes beep ha what happened he's 39
that's a young Tai Chi master yeah so
what you do is you gotta be at least 60
to be a master I know that's the Pretty
Reckless oh my god he pulled something
with his nutsack I knew it that's a chi
gong master they're different people
that what this means is we've all that
fact if chi gong penis has come to
that's right don't get it twisted
yeah so he pulled a five-ton military
helicopter what does [ __ ] dick with it
how come you don't do that I do
dude that's that's even hard to just do
it your hands I mean did he like it
didn't tear the tensile strength on his
penis is a mini plane I can't even pull
down with my arm yeah he's like it's
even hard to move like pulling with your
are tell them what can you do with your
dick well you guys will see I'll show
you a video we got a video what the
behavior one guy he's got his dick out
like look I'm not even joking yep here
we go oh why why why even work clone at
that [ __ ] point just be making the
wrong uniform he's representing what it
called perfect oh my god oh it's on
wheels did they have like the Guinness
world record something I wasn't gonna do
another name Cinco oh my god you gotta
start us how does only eight people that
give up on the punters usually like a
stadium but there's like eight people
and three of them now how did dick
hanging out of there yes good they're
gonna [ __ ] she is not impressed look at
her [ __ ] face she's like I [ __ ]
hate my job oh shoot look now I want to
look at look at her Grace's I want to
look like I'm so hard for a compound
[ __ ] can't believe I [ __ ] quit
college for this [ __ ]
she looks like she [ __ ] with like ropes
and spikes and [ __ ] she got like one of
that like [ __ ] weird Russian like
dominatrix face hmm
she is disappointed later I will suck
your caviar out of your stroll yeah so
the judges they are from world-record
specification limited which is what the
[ __ ] is that that sounds like some
[ __ ] wack ass Guinness there's no
association for them no one knows who
they are yeah I could have made one up
for him yeah we handed up winning the
certificate for the roll record of the
farthest distance for a plane to be
dragged with penis I like the epic music
not even like a plaque I want on my wall
though you know what I mean I don't want
people welcome said what's that what's
that time for you guys pull [ __ ] with my
dick [ __ ] dude very that's a true dick
measuring contest though okay how come
there's no movies on stuff like this not
like it man where he's like the best
kung fu guy right be sure there's people
that are challenging him and people
challenging five schools in the
neighborhood how come does not that one
secret dick polar and then just a new
dick polar on the block that's
challenging the other three too
or did polio that moment 100% sure I
would not want to watch movie idea I
want to watch a man's dick for two hours
here and then and then they bring in
history like the Japan occupy in China
and then after ending of this final dick
pulling contest between the Chinese and
the Japanese guy I'd watch it you think
they'll fall skin stronger than my
foreskin like that
pretty poor dead foreskin what did he
pull with oh that's right everybody
pulling cars what is dick - Wow yeah he
had previously already done this is that
two cars seven Oh dad I can't have it
full seven cars with my arm seven out
it's straight up I hope it's on neutral
issues and heroes do you guys see that
little kid in the playground just six
runs pulling his dick all day you know
that [ __ ] weirdo kid that never grew
up out of it all for the seven cars he
was using is testicles Oh God bro man I
mean III don't understand martial
artists that only train the dick like
what are you training for like what
about the follow in the knee like
there's so many other things I'm pretty
sure like what he bites somebody he just
always has to like the records quest or
something I'm pretty sure he hasn't felt
good sex procedures do anything exact on
you might give really good sex because
you can withstand anything what if he
never comes and a good just wow I like
it you're like a human dildo I feel bad
for they do you should come too you're
still giving forgiver Julia together
yeah there's this other master that
pulled Kenan
dude this is a real thing more they
should have a [ __ ] real like
dick-measuring why do agent people feel
the [ __ ] need to do this do not basic
hey hey hey dirt they're not Asian
they're kung fu masters in China ah in
the China China is a is the salt of
cultures yeah so we have to spot new
things all the pan because they're
next-level thinkers you know over here
it's like kicking and punching he's just
doing that [ __ ] like do it no no it's
because like so they look at
bodybuilding is too basic
they already been done IG [ __ ] that I'm
not going that portion of my testicle
that I never see an Asian smash it at
bodybuilding they don't need to ski
basics yeah everybody could do that
behind me people can put these with
their penis ya know by doing about 20
people nobody uh yeah I don't know I
think that should contain high doesn't
say that's what's so cool thing about it
though in a fight you kick you kick them
in the balls they're not going to flinch
this is what I was taught a knee MMA
fighter you kick them in the balls
they're gonna die but your basic skills
of survival does not include getting
kids in the balls not feeling it you
talking about now
that's one of the first things people do
on a street fight is they try to kick
you in the balls I got kids in the balls
all the time
you can't even say that with a straight
face what are you you guys he's involved
one no multiple times
why I know people weird just life [ __ ]
that's what happened then what's up guys
thanks for watching we are going to
regularly start posting content on the
JK films Instagram so make sure you
follow us there the last video click
over here
[Music]